on va parler de la semaine espagnole
avec vous Céline bonsoir ils sont en
train de Fred de Vigner
vous êtes photographe et vous participez
à cette semaine espagnole alors c'est
d'abord quel est le programme ça démarre
ça a déjà démarré avec l'exposition
photo mais ça se poursuit à partir de
lundi jusqu'au vendredi toute une
semaine rien que sur l'Espagne oui tout
à fait donc ça démarre lundi 1er octobre
jusqu'à samedi 6 octobre donc on a
essayé ça a été impulsé un petit peu
avec les adhérents avec le les
intervenants de faire des passerelles
des liens sur tout ce qui était en place
déjà au centre sur le thème de l'Espagne
donc ça va aller de la conférence en
histoire de l'art sur Goya au cours de
cuisine et plats ibérique avec une
clôture une paella une paella en clôture
bien sûr un grand repas dîner-spectacle
avec donc un enseignant de musique qui
va faire aussi un spectacle avec ses
élèves des danseuses sévillanes du
flamenco et depuis toute la semaine donc
une exposition photo une un travail de
recherche avec les différents bénévoles
de l'association sur la culture
espagnole la géographie l'histoire voilà
il y a et pourquoi donc pourquoi une
semaine espagnole sur l'Espagne ça a été
une demande d'une impulsion peut-être
une envie encore de soleil de prolonger
les surtout en ce moment surtout avec le
temps du jour et beaucoup plus je pense
qu'il y a de ça aussi et puis vraiment
une impulsion le centre Alfred de Vigny
à une 30 ans de vie locale d'un stand
Bilal de d'impulser des semaines comme
ça thématique est-ce que ça même
thématique
sur l'Espagne oui c'est la première par
contre il y a eu donc le Brésil il y a
eu la semaine l'année dernière on a fait
Alfred de Vigny pour un petit peu comme
on avait emménagé dans un nouveau lieu
le centre Alfred de Vigny avait changé
de place donc on s'est dit remettre un
petit peu pourquoi centralfred de Vigny
d'où c'était venu et on avait fait une
thématique l'année dernière sur le ce
thème là est-ce qu'on comprend cette
semaine espagnole c'est que finalement
les adhérents se l'approprient puisqu'il
participent c'est ça qui est important
c'est pas simplement pour y avoir des
gens de l'extérieur qui viennent mais
c'est aussi important que c'est vraiment
les adhérents et puis c'est ouvert à
tous bien sûr puisqu'il y a il y a
plusieurs options vous pouvez venir vous
inscrire vous pouvez découvrir le centre
par ce biais là par la espagnole donc
c'est vraiment des passerelles alors
qu'on rappelle justement ce centre
combien d'adhérents et qu'est-ce qu'on
propose elle est multitudes animations
activités effectivement on a un
catalogue assez varié on peut faire de
la danse africaine pas espagnol on peut
faire des photos comme le Photo Club
donc parlera pas et puis des cours de
langue donc de l'espagnol bien sûr on a
vraiment un catalogue riche et varié
parce qu'il y a des nouvelles il y a
toujours des nouvelles actions
en ce début de saison oui donc on a été
fait un petit peu cette année avec du
champ prénatal on accueille de
nombreuses associations plus nombreuses
que l'an dernier
quelque chose un peu nouveau et de
circonstances je dirais l'association
Solidarité nouvelle face au chômage qui
intervient qui fait des du coaching un
petit peu
dans un centre nid de lois enfin de
loisirs un centre d'activité d'animation
c'est étonnant et ça veut dire qu'il
faut se il faut se mettre au goût du
jour et que le goût du jour est pas
forcément bon goût d'ailleurs en ce
moment avec la crise mais il est c'est
des passerelles aussi je dirais puisque
on vient pour faire une activité on se
rend compte aussi que qu'on peut avoir
une aide on a aussi du développement
personnel beaucoup qui est cette année
avec de la dynamique de regroupe des
ateliers d'écriture c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment étoffé donc quand on est quand
on se laisse comme ça d'un centre ou et
puis en fait la direction on suit le
mouvement de la société pour s'adapter
évidemment aux demandes et oui
voilà Dominguez alors je l'ai dit vous
organiser une exposition de photos qui a
déjà démarré et qui dure je crois
jusqu'au donc
qui a commencé hier mercredi et qui dure
je crois jusqu'à 20 octobre alors vous
faites partie du club photo je fais
partie depuis quelques années du club
photos de voisins de
Vigny et donc
nous a donné envie de photographier le
fameux cours mais bon déjà j'aime
beaucoup la photo du spectacle tout ce
qui est spectacle pour originaire je
suis désolé
merci mais j'ai une action assez forte
bon j'espère que ma diction ne gêne pas
compréhension de ce que je veux dire oui
donc pourquoi les flamenco d'abord tout
est spectacle m'intéresse pour les
flamencoins particuliers déjà parce que
il exprime beaucoup de diversité de
d'émotions toutes les émotions les plus
douces et les plus fines et les plus
intérieurs les plus animales et les plus
voilà c'est jusqu'au plus animal vous
pouvez dire les plus passionnés les plus
les plus fortes la révolte toutes sortes
des sentiments voilà d'ailleurs c'est
c'est ça qui est important dans les
flammes plus que la gestuelle une bonne
artiste flamenco doit être capable de
vraiment espérer beaucoup d'émotions
quand on voit ses photos ce qui marque
sont les visages alors effectivement il
y a les couleurs il y a les couleurs qui
sont toujours très citoyantes et
magnifiques sont les visages quoi
c'est ce qui m'intéresse le plus c'est
les portraits les corps aussi mais quand
tu es vraiment moi j'aime bien arriver
au moment où la personne a fait
l'artiste est vraiment
on part aussi mais des sons ça qui
m'intéresse le plus comment vous arrivez
justement à saisir ce paroxysme quelques
quelques photos c'est vrai que c'est
étonnant on sent la colère on sent
toutes ces émotions douceurs
mais j'ai dit qu'on fait plusieurs
photos et après je choisis
pour une exposition donc j'ai choisi les
photos qui me plaisent les plus par
rapport à ça voilà c'est j'ai mais voilà
et vous savez d'enseigne émotion il y a
une chrétiendo aussi voilà donc il faut
arriver à ce moment-là si c'était photos
qui m'intéresse et d'ailleurs des fois
quand j'ai fait un de mes photos
des fois d'autres personnes je préfère
celle-ci là c'est trop brusque ou moi
voilà j'ai choisi ça parce que c'est là
où il y a de la vie quoi l'émotions
c'est danseurs de flamenco et ses
musiciens espagnols mais là ça a été une
coïncidence parce que bon j'ai fait un
peu
on la voit là elle est vraiment le
regard c'est où c'est le regard tout le
reste aussi m'intéresse la mise en scène
on ne voit que le regard je vous assure
des Folies Bergères mais c'est un
coulisses il va sortir sur sur scène et
donc il y a toute l'émotion du trac là
il est mémorise sa chorégraphie mais il
y a l'émotion
il y en a qui est beaucoup les flous la
vitesse moi c'est ça qui m'intéresse le
plus mais le reste
et donc après je pouvais pas trop
continuer parce que les jambes et donc
j'ai connu beaucoup de danseurs
danseuses guitariste et donc je vais
plus m'introduire voilà je suis pas
toujours facile d'être accepté surtout
ces milieux un peu particulier aussi et
les artistes n'aiment pas non plus que
n'importe qui fasse des photos alors
voilà j'ai fait des photos ça leur a plu
donc c'était maintenant qui m'appelle
alors en tout cas donc vos photos sont à
découvrir depuis mercredi jusqu'au 20
octobre au Centre Alfred de vigne de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux merci à vous deux
d'être venu en plateau puis je rappelle
donc cette semaine espagnol dont le
moment fort ont lieu entre lundi et
vendredi
prochain il y a des conférences il y a
des concerts il y a des étudier
culinaires on peut apprendre à faire la
paella
en tout cas espagnol tout ça se
déroulent donc au centre Alfred de Vigny
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur le
plateau du 7 8 une semaine espagnole et
maintenant je propose de regarder ce
reportage sur un festival de théâtre ça
s'appelle Orphée le festival à 10 ans et
sa particularité c'est d'accueillir des
comédiens handicapés on regarde
le mec il m'attrape par le bout de la
canne on va monter dans le métro là une
fois là Miro a perdu la vue il y a 18
ans à cause d'une dégénérescence de la
rétine il quitte alors son métier de
kinésithérapeute et décide de se lancer
dans le spectacle pour proposer un
humour pédagogique
j'explique j'explique en fait comment ça
se passe avec un chien et puis après
comment ça se passe avec une canne et
après ça commence à se passe quand on
est malvoyant mais tout ça en fait c'est
pédagogique instructif je veux apprendre
le but c'est on rit pas pour rire mais
on rit pour apprendre en fait je me sers
du rire comme moyen d'apprentissage
moi persuadé que c'était moi si vous
voulez c'est une vieille carte vous
voyez j'ai pas fait trop peur depuis 20
ans cette année Miro se produira sur la
scène de la Royal Factory dans le cadre
du festival Orphée festival européen
aient théâtre et Handicap on peut
travailler avec des personnes
handicapées et faire un travail
professionnel de qualité et c'est aussi
le but du festival j'ai mis en
adéquation ce qui était l'art souvent
dans la défense des causes perdue
justement avec des gens dont on dit que
la cause est perdue c'est ça aussi la
grande force je crois du projet Rudy
c'est d'Orphée aussi c'est c'est d'être
dans la réalité on fait avec les gens on
assiste pas les gens fait avec eux
Michel Raynaud directeur artistique du
festival mais aussi en scène les
comédiens du Théâtre Eurydice un ESAT
basé sur plaisir il présenteront une
adaptation des exercices de style de
Raymond Queneau au théâtre montencier
qu'est-ce que vous ressentez comme vous
êtes sur scène
et puis j'ai toujours le trac avant puis
là c'est encore plus impressionnant
parce que c'est avec la salle les
spectateurs
comme le disait mon psy j'ai besoin de
reconnaissance donc c'est important puis
ça m'a permis au début de sortir de la
timidité parce que j'étais très timide
et puis ça m'a permis de prendre
confiance en moi aussi et puis ça m'a
permis de aussi d'être un plaisir de ce
qui est génial la dixième édition du
festival Orphée s'ouvrira vendredi 28
septembre pour s'achever samedi 20
octobre le programme complet est à
retrouver sur internet
donc le fessier à leur fait jusqu'au 20
octobre 7 8 est terminée merci de votre
attention notez que le 7 8 de lundi
prochain sera presque intégralement
consacré au Mondial de l'Auto qui ouvre
ses portes ce vendredi vous retrouverez
l'équipe de la rédaction dans les allées
du salon afin de nous présenter
notamment les nouveautés des
constructeurs élinois ce sera donc lundi
à partir de 18h merci encore de votre
attention de ma vendredi vous retrouver
Johanna Soudry pour le 7 8 weekend bonne
soirée à très vite